this meeting setting up to be so
contentious in fact sasha loftis had to
tape this report because of the rowdy
crowd waiting for the doors to open
here's a preview of that meeting
[Music]
tonight's special meeting with ccsd
trustees is set to start any moment now
and you can see there is a large group
of protesters behind me things are
already getting heated now trustees are
set to vote on whether to move forward
with the covid 19 vaccine mandate for
district employees tonight this special
meeting follows the lead of several
other districts all around the nation
that have taken this action one reason
district leaders are considering this as
many kids are still too young to get
vaccinated if the school board votes for
the resolution today this would give
superintendent dr jesus jarrah the power
to establish a vaccine policy we spoke
with several people last week who shared
their thoughts on either side of this
action i'm for the teachers getting
vaccinated i think everybody should get
vaccinated as long as their health is
allows them to do it i feel that it sets
a dangerous precedent
i think that if they're able to vote in
a mandate for employees
the next special meeting they call will
be to mandate it for our children if
this resolution does move forward
tonight there's no word on when it would
go into effect or be enforced the
district has had a mask mandate in place
since kids returned to class on august
9. now as of today there are
1651 positive covid cases across the
clark county school district 980 of
those cases are students that's
according to the ccsd website make sure
to stay with 8 news now we will be here
for this meeting tonight and we'll keep
you updated on air and online as it
develops reporting downtown tonight
sasha loftis 8 news now
sasha thank you the school district is
also asking you your opinion on where to
use 770 million dollars in federal
funding it is called the focus on the
future for kids community input process
just head to
future.ccsd.net we also have a link on
our website eightnewsnow.com